i want to point out something um you are
figuring out a way to still be
fashionable even during this
pandemic check this out i know that you
don't need to check it out but i want my
audience to see
this is you matching your mask to your
shoes which
is i mean i can't that's high level
conan yeah that is that is operating
in the upper 99th percentile
who thinks of that that's incredible
you're figuring out a way to make
the mask a fashion statement let me tell
you who thinks of that a fashion icon
but you're not a fashion icon wait a
minute no it's all right she is
um conan here's the thing i
don't go anywhere i am one of those
people who is terrified
of this pandemic and covid and so if
there were some sort of actual bubble i
could be in i would do it
that was me visiting my products at ulta
because ulta beauty carries pattern my
hair care products
and i wanted to see them because we have
a whole bunch of new shelf space
so while i've been home i have
continued shopping and it's a lot of
masks so i have purchased some
a beautiful collection of masks that
never get used
and that day i got to coordinate
nice nice but most you know i just go
to work with the mask and and then i'm
home i don't go anywhere
you you mentioned uh you have this uh
hair care line
yes so my my hair care line is called
pattern and it
uh on it's in stores at ulta beauty
right and then it's also available
online i think you might be as hair
obsessed as i am
i've been hair obsessed since i was a
kid
i wanted my hair to look like elvis i
wanted it to look like
jack lord on hawaii 5-0 i wanted a
swoosh and a sweep and um i never grew
out of it i don't know what the problem
is so maybe you have some products
do you have anything that i could use or
is it is it no guys allowed
no first of all i don't think hair has a
gender and i agree with you
i feel like it's hair is a form of a
form of expression and it's one of the
ways i know for you like it's like an
extension of your personality for me too
my favorite thing is when you do this
yeah whatever you do
yes it's one of my favorite things to do
it's one of my favorite things you know
it's interesting it started out as what
i
i thought that it was my way of
attracting
a possible female mate and then it
turned out that it was really just a cry
for help
so once that was explained to me i made
my peace with it
no one was attracted to this they they
found it interesting
but i think my wife married me despite
the croissant
i i don't know i bet you if we talk to
your wife she would say that your hair
is also if
did she would say it's the third party
in your relationship
but possibly true yeah i do think i have
products that would work for you
the styling products because especially
if you like a swoop and a swirl
oh yeah and you know what i mean and you
want to get some like height
out of that hair yeah i bet you that our
you know
probably our stronghold gel or one of
those would work
i'm going to check it out i'm going to
check it out because i'm always looking
for the equivalent of
hair viagra and it sounds like you have
that this sounds like this gel you have
could be really helping me you know
the i don't know that i've ever um
called it that but in in on
on that path i would say that at my hair
company
size matters so maybe
maybe it does go with it
we have a video of you playing with your
hair on uh i guess this was on instagram
[Music]
what
what i love about that is again um
when you when people learn to have fun
with their hair
i mean you suddenly there are i spent
hours without an iphone
because i'm just messing around with
this thing and i think i'm
better and better for it in order for us
to keep each other safe and to
possibly move through this pandemic at
some point
i think we've all had to really change
our
habits and sort of what we lean to and
so if
giving your hair a swirl and spending 10
minutes playing stupidly with yourself
i think it's worth it you should phrase
that differently uh
probably
you